yesterday we did this story about the
draft-dodger
president Donald Trump slamming deputy
sheriff's officer deputy sheriff I guess
he was sheriff's deputy Scott Peterson
who was armed and at the school involved
in the parkland Florida shooting but did
not run towards the shooter and Donald
Trump called them lacking courage he
said maybe he's a coward Trump said all
sorts of horrible things about Scott
Peterson and I really took it as an
opportunity to point out that guns in
these situations don't necessarily make
the situation's better and they can
actually make them worse and Trump has
been getting called out for his
ridiculous comments about the coward
Scott Peterson and rightly so and now
Trump is on the defensive saying just
flat-out really dumb things this seems
to have gotten to trump and triggered
him to say just flat-out stupid ignorant
things Trump now is claiming if he had
been at the school even without a gun he
who would have run directly into the
school and directly towards the gunman
armed with an ar-15 style rifle period
and let's take a listen to how Trump
said it all right
the way they performed was frankly
disgusting they were listening to what
was going on the one in particular he
was then he was earlier than you had
three others that probably a similar
deal a little bit later but a similar
kind of a thing you know I really
believe you don't know until you test it
but I think I really believe I'd run in
there even if I didn't have a weapon and
I think most of the people in this room
would have done that too because I know
most of you but the way they performed
was was really a disgrace
so listen aside from whether it makes
sense for a president to talk like this
aside from whether it would be logical
for Trump to run in or for Trump not to
run in there is no chance in hell that
Donald Trump is running in there and in
fact we have Trump on record talking
about how he's such a germaphobe he told
the story on the Howard Stern Show once
about how he was once at his
Club mar-a-lago in Florida and he thinks
a guy was dying in front of him and the
guy was bleeding and Trump just turned
away here's the quote from Trump's
interview with Howard Stern where he
said I was at mar-a-lago and we had this
incredible ball the Red Cross ball in
Palm Beach Florida and we had the
Marines and the Marines were there and
it was terrible because all these rich
people they're there to support the
Marines but they're really there to get
their picture in the palm beach posts so
you have all these really rich people
and a man about 80 years old very
wealthy man a lot of people didn't like
him he fell off the stage so what
happens is this guy falls off right on
his face hits his head and I thought he
died and you know what I did I said oh
my god that's disgusting and I turned
away I couldn't you know he was right in
front of me and I turned away I didn't
want to touch him he's bleeding all over
the place I felt terrible you know
beautiful marble floor didn't look like
it it changed color became very red and
you have this poor guy 80 years old
laying on the floor unconscious and all
the rich people are turning away oh my
god this is terrible this is disgusting
and you know they're turning away nobody
wants to help the guy his wife is
screaming she's sitting right next to
him and she's screaming ladies and
gentlemen the President of the United
States you're telling me that at his own
club he won't help a bleeding guy and
were expected to believe he'd run
unarmed into a school where a mass
shooting is taking place and never mind
violence here's a picture of Trump not
even protecting his own kid baron from
the rain here's Trump shielding himself
with a huge umbrella while his kid is
just getting soaked by rain the
delusions are getting worse
folks much much worse it's probably time
to up the meds and I would guess in any
case that Trump's bone spurs would
prevent him from running into the school
anyway at mostly to be able to walk in
there slowly I cannot believe that
anyone buys this guy's BS he's sort of
becoming Kim jong-il remember when the
late Kim jong-il would say he shot 11
holes of golf his first time playing I'm
sorry
11 holes in one his first time playing
golf he was walking when he was only
three weeks old and I think speaking
fluent Korean when he was seven or eight
weeks old
and yet if you watch videos from CPAC
you understand why people believe him
because they all believe the BS
that is being spoon-fed to them by these
speakers I'm gonna be a naysayer here I
actually give Trump a pass for this
comment because I think he gave enough
qualifiers one he said that he believes
he would do this well I do not that he
actually would the other the other pass
would be that he said that you never
really know until you're tested and I
think that is true yeah I mean I've
talked before about how I
I genuinely don't know what I would do
if I was on an airplane and what I
believed to be an attempt to hijack the
plane went down right yeah at times I
think you know I think I would try to
get involved in do something at other
times I think I might not not
necessarily for fear but partially
because I wouldn't want to accidentally
maybe make the situation worse he did
qualify it but do we even really believe
Trump believes he would run towards the
shooter I don't know he actually might
he does have delusions of grandeur such
that maybe he actually does believe he
would run towards the shooter with no
gun it's a way to be it's a way to get
credit for being a hero without actually
doing anyone yeah to be totally fair to
Trump
I mean I'll sort of do another sort of
Pat like comment in which I will not
really defend Trump but I'll say this
isn't as bad as it could be this isn't a
particularly huge lie or delusion Trump
is telling way bigger lies and
experiencing much bigger delusions every
day
this one's relatively Petty and childish
but it's the entire toxic atmosphere
that's that's come from the right after
this shooting that I think Trump is sort
of contributing to with his comments